après le dans à peu près dans cette
maison de salaberry de valleyfield le
week-end c'est le temps de grand
déjeuner en famille et de faire sa part
pour l'environnement
c'est un cadre infirmier de dans ce
qu'on a fait c'est qu'on s'est racheté
un contenant actuellement dans la
poubelle domestique et celui 16 puis ont
levé dans au moins deux fois par jour on
va le porter dans le compost à
l'extérieur ici on fait son propre
compostage en attendant d'avoir accès
aux services de collecte de la ville
toutes les maisons ne sont pas desservis
on y voit un projet pilote justement
pour tester notre territoire avant le
déploiement grande échelle qui est
prévue pour 2019
actuellement seulement 30% des
municipalités au québec offrent la
collecte des matières compostables
c'est très lent comme avant c'est ce
sont surtout des petites municipalités
qui sont avancés qui ont des programmes
qui sont déjà en place au niveau des
grandes municipalités comme montréal ou
ou québec il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire la première politique
québécoise du recyclage et du compostage
a été lancée il ya près de 30 ans les
villes ont adopté rapidement l'option du
recyclage parce qu'elle était plus
simple mais pour le compostage
il a longtemps été plus avantageux
d'enfouir les matières putrescibles
puisque ça coûtait moins cher
québec ensuite fixer des objectifs plus
ambitieux le gouvernement prévoyait
recycler 60 % des matières organiques en
2015 et 100 % en 2020 mais il a revu ses
cibles 60% pour la fin de l'année 2018
et 100% pour 2022 on peut souhaiter des
choses mais quand on aurait pour le
mettre à plat souvent là ça exige des
délais ont fait face à des réalités à
une acceptabilité sociale aussi parce
qu'on ne peut pas parler de transformer
l'organique que ce soit en compost ou en
gare sans avoir la participation
citoyens l'union des municipalités du
québec dit malgré tout être sur la bonne
voie que de plus en plus des citoyens
font leur part
ouais ok je vais ap on le met dedans
il se marie laurence de l'aîné radio
canada salaberry-de-valleyfield